les faits remontent au 9 mai 2018 et
l'évacuation des grévistes de
l'université jean jaurès par les forces
de l'ordre
ce jour-là guillem étudiant en lettres
et blessés par l'explosion d'une grenade
de désencerclement lors de son
interpellation devant la gare matabiau
de toulouse
concrètement je n'ai pas pu voir ce qui
se passait parce que j'étais maintenu
les deux bras et le regard fixé vers le
ciel je j'ai pu rien faire je ne pouvais
même pas me débattre donc j'ai pas pu
voir ce qui s'est passé concrètement
tout ce que je sais c'est que une
grenade a explosé dans mon dos sans que
je ne comprenne rien ce qui se passe est
censé avoir aucune explication de la
raison de cette explosion
j'aurais proches à l'état d'avoir armé
des policiers visiblement qui ne savent
pas se servir de leurs armes
ou alors qu'il s'en sert de façon de ce
sont de façon disproportionnée l'
affaire a été classée sans suite par le
parquet la responsabilité des policiers
écarté cette affaire est déjà passé
devant l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
les collègues ont été totalement
blanchis pour la bonne et simple raison
que c'est un déclenchement accidentel de
la grenade qui a blessé et le monsieur
en question
guilhem et les deux autres
fonctionnaires entre autres fonctions de
policier on ne comprend pas l'action de
ses avocats si ce n'est que c'est un
coup politique
alors on peut enlever par les deux
jeunes essaient de détourner ce monsieur
n'est pas venu je crois plus aux
convocations de police il a été il a été
il a été convoqué pour être entendu il
ne s'est jamais rendu aux convocations
donc il a quelque chose à se reprocher
si les policiers on était dédouané par
l'igpn les avocates de guillem ne compte
pas en rester là
ce qu'on espère c'est déjà que la
personne guillem soient dédommagés qui
puisse y avoir à nouveau une expertise
médicale pour refaire le point sur la
situation de guillem ensuite des
dommages et intérêts parce que j'aime
pour l'instant n'a pas été indemnisé sur
le préjudice subi qui est très important
à préjudice physique un préjudice
psychologique et on demande aussi à ce
que l'état réponde à ces questions là
c'est à dire en fait l'agent judiciaire
de l'état qui doit répondre à nos
questions à savoir est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal d'utiliser la
technique d'étranglement est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal
sortir une grenade de désencerclement
lorsqu'on est policier judiciaire
interpellateurs et nous expliquer et
bien comment ça fonctionne
et pourquoi pourquoi ces permis et est
ce que là dessus l'état se questionne
sur ces méthodes là le jeune homme et
ses avocats espèrent obtenir des
dommages et intérêts mais aussi engager
la responsabilité de l'état